that's pretty much all the new stuff we
can talk about because we don't have
mafia three yet the game is coming out
in just a couple of days and typically
at this point we would have a review out
the name of the game this time around
like it was with doom is that no copies
are coming out until release day that
can often ring alarm bells for some
people but whose to really say cuz doom
turned out really well um Scott you're
gonna be the one reviewing this game I
am and you have the unfortunate duty of
doing it you know with without maybe a
finish line in mind yeah but you know in
your mind is this really a bad sign that
this game is coming out late I mean have
you had a chance to play any of it at
events thus far only once in a very
limited capacity so it's really not
enough to like color my perception of
the game I mean I I love what they're
doing thigh matically I'm excited about
the setting I'm excited my characters I
like that they've gone could have
committed to a fully open world game so
there are a lot of reasons I think it
might be really great yeah sometimes if
you don't get review copies ahead of a
game's launch that can be a sign that
you know there-there's something to hide
and you know the publisher doesn't have
faith in the product and therefore they
don't want people reading reviews but
that's also totally not necessarily the
case I mean doom is a great example as
you just pointed out of a game that was
actually really great and that again we
just didn't get until like day of if not
like you may have actually I think went
out and bought a copy from what I
remember we used an Australian PSN
account to download it ya know I think
the one thing to consider here you know
you bring up the sort of the themes in
this game which deal a lot with race
during a time in America's history which
is super tumultuous and it begs the
question maybe they're scared of people
reading reactions to that you know the
marketing behind this game has been
pretty consistent and loud for a long
time now and it's almost like that
they'd rather have the marketing speak
for the game then other people sort of
impart their opinion on how they're
handling something so potentially
caustic right now I mean it's it's one
thing if they they're really confident
that they've nailed it but how can you
be confident about speaking about
something so controversial especially
this year when things that kind of hit
the fan in a way just a little um I mean
it's entirely possible that they don't
want controversy to
klipsch the game itself yeah that is a
very interesting theory I mean honestly
who's to say that's something we'd have
to talk to the publishers and developers
about but that is entirely possible
because you're very right this game is
approaching some very difficult subject
matter or some stuff that has sort of
proven to be touchy especially among
gamers and yet to sort of broach those
topics in a serious way in a way that's
not going to be comfortable for a lot of
people naturally that's going to become
a focus for certain crowds for certain
audiences and there is definitely a
chance that the noise or the reaction
that comes from that will overshadow the
game itself so wanting to avoid that
makes a lot of sense I have no idea if
that's what's happening but there's a
lot of weight behind that theory like
that that makes a great deal of sense I
mean it's very difficult to say but this
game has been in development for a while
and we've seen it in quite as finished
form you know for some time right we've
had recent events where people had to
play a large chunk of the game so it
really does make the question where are
these copies and this is not as tale of
us being sad that we don't get to play
the game will get to play it eventually
like a lot of people but in a sense
reviews kind of do a service for the
consumer right yeah because pre-orders
are such a thing in video games now
where people feel compelled to get the
game on day one and there you know
stoked with like pre order items and all
these other exclusives that reviews are
sort of the only line of defense in some
ways to protect people from when a game
really isn't as good as the company is
claiming it to be so I think that is
actually the bigger problem here so I
don't want people to think that we're
whining that like oh we don't get to
play the game yet and our job is that
difficult but it's actually a concern
for everybody because a lot of people
put down 60 bucks without much beyond an
advertisement here or a video there yeah
and a lower key I mean I will say that
if people are concerned if if you heard
this news and you thought like they have
something to hide clearly this game is
gonna you know be awful and they've been
lying this all this time like if that
was your reaction then wait like we are
going to review the game we are
absolutely gonna review it it'll our
review will probably go up sometime next
week we're going to get it done as
efficiently as we can obviously as our
other outlets so I mean if if people out
there actually concerned if they if they
need a review to validate an opinion or
if they want to be certain that they're
buying something that's going to be
worth their money give it a couple days
like
you're you're you're not wrong that
pre-orders are pushed more and more and
that has totally become a thing and you
know maybe the people who preordered are
confident that they're gonna love it no
matter what but if you haven't
pre-ordered and if you are concerned
just wait don't buy it they won like
read reviews uh wait and hear what your
friends think you know watch youtubers
play it I guarantee this me a ton people
streaming on twitch like make up your
mind you can you can gather information
from so many sources these days that you
know if it turns out the game is
terrible and it isn't worth your money
you will know you figure that out so
like I don't know I don't interpret this
as like you know necessarily a bad sign
I don't think that it's necessarily you
know like the developers the publisher
trying to lie to their audience or
something right I think it's just like
they made a strategic choice and that's
their right because it's their products
like we are not know Scott you know we
don't deserve I did look I'm with you a
hundred percent unreached the choir I'm
not saying this is bad for this I'm not
saying this means the game is bad bro no
but I think people sometimes make that
assumption I have seen that in comment
section right no I just want to be clear
that like this is not saying that they
have something necessarily to hide like
a bad German people are going to feel
duped but at the same time it is highly
unusual behavior right that only occurs
a few times a year with very specific
games with doom there's really no we
don't know why yeah there I we never
really got an explanation why and it
turned out that hey everything was fine
with mafia you know who really knows
like this game I think yeah I just
worried that it's about the controversy
I worry that that is the reason again I
have no freakin knowledge yeah i'm sure
there's like a day one patch that they
want to like you know tidy everything up
there like so many big games but so many
those big games we also get ahead of
time on those damn one patches sure they
may make a difference but they don't
really impact the entire game at large
it's really something that like please
the developer in a way right the
creator's behind it so i'm a little
disappointed that i guess that they're
not willing to put their a confident
foot forward and give this out and
that's how i feel about it that's fair
yeah all right well mafia 3 is coming
out soon we will have a review are you
looking forward to the game i think
everyone should give it a shot just
because of the things that's tackling
it's a really rare we get these subject
matters in games but let us know how you
feel in the comments below
you
[Music]